in two recent videos links in
description we looked at William PK's
2018 book Crusade and Jihad the
Thousand-Year war between the Muslim
world and the global North in the first
video I showed how only about 5% of the
book covered that is to say whitewashed
the first Millennium of conflict which
largely featured Muslims invading and
conquering the lands of and massacring
and enslaving Christians in the second
video we saw that the rest of his book
95 % of it was dedicated to the last
couple of centuries beginning with the
colonial era when finally the West had
reached its Zenith and the Muslim world
its Nader thanks to this intentionally
lopsided approach pulk manages to give
the impression that the Christian West
has always been the aggressor and Islam
has always been its victim from here he
and so many other academics and experts
are able to do something else they're
able to present all the problems
currently plaguing the Muslim World from
so socioeconomic political problems to
rampant radicalization and terrorism as
a byproduct of you guessed it Western
interference and exploitation Islam
files like pul are committed to two
premises one that for centuries Islam
was a beacon of light in a dark world
and thus something must have gone
horribly wrong since and two that which
went wrong begins and ends with Western
meddling via colonization Etc as should
be evident by now and if you haven't
watched the first two videos I made
about this book the reverse is true
Islam always did what Islam does and was
constrained only during that brief era
of Western assertion the colonial era
the greater irony is that whereas jihads
often culminated in slavery depopulation
and Devastation European colonialists
abolished slavery and introduced their
Muslim subjects to the boons of
modernity from scientific and medical
advances to the radical concepts of
democracy and religious Freedom writing
in the early 20th century a Coptic
Christian summarized the status of Egypt
under British rule as follows in a word
we say that the Egyptian state was at
the highest degree of justice and good
order and Arrangement and it removed
religious fanaticism and almost
established equality between its
subjects Christian and Muslim he's
talking about British rule and it
eliminated most of the Injustice and it
realized much in the way of beneficial
work for the benefit of all the
inhabitants or consider how North Africa
was once among the most prosperous and
civilized regions of Christendom in the
7th Century before the Islamic conquest
was home to Carthage home to St
Augustine and so forth but centuries of
jihad ransacking in the enslavement of
countless Souls turned it into a desert
then once it was entirely populated by
Muslims North Africa subsisted entirely
on enslaving Europeans centuries before
the colonial era in fact the United
States of America's first war as a
nation was with these barbery states as
the Christians refer to North Africa
Land Of The Barbarians when Thomas
Jefferson and John Adams asked barbar's
Ambassador why his countrymen were
enslaving American Sailors he said
nothing about open scars or the anger
and frustration of Muslims to use PK's
words rather Jefferson wrote to Congress
the quote Ambassador answered us that it
was founded on the law of their Prophet
that it was written in the Quran that it
was their right and duty to make war
upon them non-muslims wherever they
could be found and to make slaves of all
they could take as prisoners had had
Thomas Jefferson actually known the
Ambassador was paraphrasing Quran 995
the sword verse at any rate and rather
sadly Crusade and Jihad represents the
academic and mainstream opinion
concerning Islam and the West as is
typical of the social sciences
increasingly the hard Sciences as well a
reality in this case history has been
recast to conform to the accepted
narrative one which follows a rather
familiar Matrix anything white and
Christian equals hypocrisy intolerance
greed exploitation anything non-white
non-Christian equals honesty tolerance
fair-mindedness advancement and
benevolence thus and despite how Muslims
persecuted Spain's Christians for
centuries here is how pulk describes the
indigenous liberators the Christians
Visa the invading
occupiers over the centuries the warlike
Christian States pushed South into the
peninsula of Spain until in 1492 they
drove away tens of thousands of Muslims
and put an end to one of the most
advanced Societies in Europe the lesson
is clear from a historical point of view
from fake history Islam can do no wrong
even when it invades conquers persecutes
and the West can do no right even when
it defends liberates and civilizes while
we are to exonerate contemporary Muslim
terrorism as a product of grievances
against an imagined or rather fake
history of colonialism and abuse only
condemnation remains for those premodern
Christians who set so many wrongs to
rights such are the pseudo histories
that have long plagued the West's
understanding of its relationship to
Islam it's in large part to combat these
false narratives that I wrote my book
sword and AR 14 centuries of war between
Islam and the West not only does it
document the politically incorrect facts
of history but every Century gets its
Fair due